[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone it's seven o'clock in the uk
welcome wherever you're watching us
around the world this morning is there
perhaps
a glimmer of hope for that summer
getaway overseas
after all the government's considering
allowing british holiday makers to head
off to amber listed destinations without
the need to quarantine on return
if they've had both kovy jabs but that
comes as new scientific research
suggests that cases are rising rapidly
right across england plenty then to
discuss with the financial secretary to
the treasury jesse norman in just a few
moments
time also asthma has been a part of my
life from a young age
i've grown to deal with it and see it as
part of who i am today
asthma for six we'll be talking to the
england cricketer stuart broad who's
part of a campaign to raise awareness
of the condition amongst children that's
at half past nine in addition to that
[Music]
and how the whole of the moon triggered
a whole lot of memories will speak
to that man thomas leeds about how this
80s classic
brought flashbacks after a teenage head
injury
robbed him of his memory that's at
around 8 45.
it's thursday the 17th of june
cleared for takeoff and landing
ministers consider scrapping the need to
quarantine
on return from amber list countries if
you've had both kobe jabs
but it comes as a new study warns coving
cases arising rapidly in england pushing
the so-called r-rate to more than 1.4
ending the stalemate in stormont shin
fein and the dup reach an agreement to
prevent the collapse of power sharing in
northern ireland
lessons to be learnt a survivor of the
manchester arena bombing speaks out
as a report in security arrangements on
the night is published
you think why wasn't this picked up on
i'm understanding but i am resentful i'm
angry
we have liftoff china launches three
astronauts into orbit
they'll spend three months on the
country's new space station and for the
vast majority of the uk and ireland it's
going to be fine
and sunny but for most of england
thundery downpours will continue over
the next few days i'll have the full
details
and don't forget hay fever has loads and
loads of hay fever if like me you're
suffering this morning my sincerest
condolences we'll hear what the
pollen levels are like from nas later on
meantime
the government says it's considering
plans to relax restrictions
on international travel for britons
who've had both coronavirus vaccines
it could mean travelers who've had both
jabs would be able to travel to
ambulance countries
without having to self-isolate when they
come home
but it comes as a new study from react
warns covet cases are rising
exponentially in england
with the all-important r-rate now at
more than 1.4
let's speak to charlotte lomas who's
standing by in the newsroom for us this
morning hello to you
charlotte so potentially we could go on
holiday but
also potentially countries won't let us
in because of our rate going up so high
yes i mean we really do have to manage
our expectations here it's not going to
be an ease of restrictions
imminently but we do know that the
government officials now are
looking into the possibility of trying
to allow britons who have had
both of their covered vaccinations to
travel to some popular
destinations without having to
quarantine when they return now these
countries include france spain
italy and the us but as you mentioned
there
you will still have to adhere to the
rule set by your
destination country and there will still
be a need for tests
so as yet we just have to monitor the
situation but we do understand that the
government is
looking into trying to ease up movement
between
two countries now as you mentioned there
okay this does come
as a new scientific study is released
the latest one
the react study highly significant from
the imperial
college london which has shown that
there's been a rise in the number of
infections
by 50 percent this is mainly driven by
the
delta variant and the bulk of cases
has been found in younger children aged
between 5 and 12
and also younger adults age between 18
and 24
these unvaccinated age groups now let me
run you through this study in a bit
finer
detail this latest react study estimates
that the
r number the rate of infection growth
is now 1.45 infections have increased
50 percent as i mentioned between may
the 3rd and june the 7th
this coinciding with the rise of the
delta coronavirus variant and in that
period
covid19 cases doubled every 11 days
with the highest prevalence being in the
north west in areas like manchester
and lancashire the data's also showed
that for those aged over
65 the weakened link between infection
rate and hospital admissions
was well maintained also suggesting that
the expansion
of the vaccine program to those aged 18
and above
should help substantially to reduce the
overall growth
of the epidemic so while these numbers
are alarming um and there is a reason
for concern the authors of this study
have also pointed that we are in a very
different position now than we were
in previous periods of growth like in
the spring and
in the autumn where we can get some
comfort
in the fact from the vaccination pro
there is some immunity
and protection thank you charlotte well
let's speak to the
financial secretary to the treasury
joining us this morning jesse norman
hello to you thank you for joining us
this morning mr norman good morning good
morning
thank you good morning are you
considering is the government
considering
opening holiday routes amber holiday
routes for those who have had two jobs
well the government's uh keeping all of
these uh
fast moving developments under uh a
fairly close scrutiny as you might
imagine
uh we're keenly aware of the concerns
that people have
uh there's a lot of desire of course to
travel but we have to be prudent we have
to be careful we have to be cautious and
at the same time we have to respect
the needs of people in other countries
which have their own
public health issues so it's a complex
picture but we're trying to do all we
can
to proceed forward as it were safely and
and appropriately given all the
different factors in play
so it's fair to say the government is
considering it it's certainly looking at
all the options here and
we don't want to get left behind by
countries which may be adopting uh
two jabs approach uh if it can be done
safely and if it can be done
carefully and securely so people
watching at home this morning over their
brexit shouldn't write off
foreign holidays this summer just yet
okay you know you you see the
fast-moving situation just as much as we
do um
uh uh you know we are we are trying to
move cautiously
and progressively in the right direction
so i wouldn't write anything off at this
point but then uh
you know uh we are in a situation where
the vaccine
is not something we control uh sorry the
virus is not something we control and
we have seen this new delta variant and
therefore you know it would be imprudent
to
to to to make any cop blush or as it
were firm statement now
if we do does that not discriminate
against under 30s
who by the robot that we have in the
united kingdom would not be able to
travel because they haven't had both
jabs
well i think that's a certainly a
consideration to be born in mind of
course the under 30s
uh do not have anything like the same
vulnerability to
the disease that people older do and
as you will be aware the government is
accelerating the rollout of vaccinations
as
fast as uh it can and that's been a very
important part of the thinking over the
last
few days as you will know about uh uh
how long this present period of
restriction should last for
but you do accept that um if we do go
ahead with uh two vaccinations and you
can travel that does discriminate
against the under 30.
okay we're you're putting us in the
world of the remote hypotheticals let's
see where we get to and then we can have
a
conversation about balancing the needs
of all the people concerned and
you know it may well be that there are
approaches we can take that
uh are uh able to meet the needs of
people who aren't fully vaccinated let's
just wait and
see how that evolves except not remote
hypotheticals because you when we first
started chatting you were saying that
you know everything
is being considered that's true and
uh of course this is one of those things
that's being considered but uh
you know i think it would have been a
brave person to suggest they could have
predicted the course of the virus
even a few weeks ago okay so uh
predicting it now
is not any easier than it is it is then
and uh of course
we are balancing not just public health
issues and economic issues but also
as you've rightly highly highlighted
issues of equity and fairness as well
okay um let me ask you about people
staying at home come the 19th
of july what will the government message
be
about people returning to the office
well uh uh of course
that message is going to be one which uh
will have to be announced in due course
but uh of course we
we want a balanced return to
work we want people to maintain safety
and security we have this priceless
achievement of a breathing space that
vaccinations have given us
and uh the potential for opening up the
economy economy is growing
i'm pleased to say bouncing back very
quickly and we need to be able to
safeguard and preserve that
would you be happy for your staff to
work from home say rather than the
treasury
well uh every company and every
as it were different organization is
going to want to have different
approaches and there are certainly
people who are affected differently by
lockdown and their needs have to be
attended to and listen to uh just as
much as
anyone else's you would have seen there
are some institutions which are
taking your view that it's really
essential that people should be in the
office and it's unfair uh to younger
people in their judgment
uh not to do that because of the
opportunities to grow and to develop
people's
skills and to bring them on in the
organization so again this is going to
be very
company or organization specific and uh
you know any guidance the government
puts out is going to have to recognize
that
well they did of course that you the
government did uh offer some advice back
in your manifesto of 2019
we will encourage flexible working and
consult on making it the default unless
employers
have good reason not to so even before
we knew about the virus you were
basically saying people
should work from home if they can no i
don't think we're saying that at all i
don't think consulting on flexible
working is reaching a
view what it's saying is the patterns of
work were evolving
before the virus and as many as in many
cases the effect of a pandemic effect of
a national crisis is to accelerate
the process of change and that's
certainly happened there are many parts
of
our lives now where people wouldn't go
back i think you spoke to many gps they
would say that actually
the opportunity to do telemedicine has
made their
lives able to accommodate many more
patients than they had
uh previously contemplated and there are
many other parts of
life where it would be lovely to think
that working for him gave benefits
uh as well and productivity benefits the
economy as well as
personal benefits to the individuals as
employees well the government website
seems to think that that's the case
flexible working is a way of working
that suits an employee's
needs um including working from home
well i i don't think that's untrue is it
okay that seems a
robust statement of point i'm trying to
clarify for my viewers this morning is
when come the 19th of july do they send
the kids off to school and then go up to
the spare bedroom to work from home
or is the government's view that they
should probably go into what into the
office
well let us see where we get to uh uh
on the 19th of july but i think the
government's already flanked as you have
indicated through the
manifesto that uh it is uh
aware of the shifts in uh the way in
which people work and
the desire for flexible working and in
this case working from home and
of course as i've said it will be
something that very much varies by
organizations as well as by different
kinds of employees and different ages of
employees so
again i don't think there's a there's a
there's a particular rule that we could
or should lay down at this point
the former cbi boss digby jones
disagrees he thinks it's uh going to
drag us back into the 1970s in his words
instill low ambition and that we risk
becoming a
zombie nation why is he wrong
well i i listen i've known digby for
many years and uh
he's a man of extremely colorful
opinions and occasionally accurate ones
listen it's going to be helping many
people and
it may not suit other people and we just
need to be
uh aware of that and organizations need
to be flexible enough
and of course companies want to bring on
their employees companies have no
interest in going backwards
even if what digby was said was true
about about the nature of employment i
think in many ways
employment is uh becoming something
that's
because it's more flexible it's more uh
amenable to different people it allows
people to grow in different ways and
if it doesn't then companies need to
think about how they can support people
uh in their own uh workforces their own
staffs to develop their own skills and
come on forward themselves does the pm
still think his health secretary is
hopeless
look um i think you're referring to some
of the revelations yesterday
uh okay i have no idea what the prime
minister thinks about these
uh matters uh and uh i can tell you i
what we've been presented with is one
side of
a snapshot of a conversation
that um i have no idea if it's true or
false at
you know in the middle of the worst
economic
social and uh public health crisis we've
had for
a hundred years so um you know is it
would it be surprising if the odd
snapshot
uh uh you know portrayed in a certain
light uh
gave a certain view to people i i have
no idea you know it's uh it's uh
uh it's again you you you're uh focusing
on a very particular element in a much
wider picture which is that
we're in this crisis uh the health
secretary has been
battling valiantly and in many ways
highly effectively through that
uh in order to make that work you know
i'm just asking you in your opinion
given that you are a government minister
whether you
think the prime minister still thinks
his health secretary is hopeless i think
that's a reasonable question
it's a perfectly reasonable question i
have no idea he hasn't consulted me on
the matter
i think there's every reason to think
that he thinks that he'll give you the
impression
that he he has complete faith in his
health
he gives me the impression of thinking
that the health secretary is doing
a very good job under very difficult
circumstances and rightly citizen i've
worked with matt hancock
in the past and is a very very effective
and skilled operator so
um uh you know those matters speak for
themselves
let me ask you about the infrastructure
bank which is your area of expertise
what sort of initiative is it how is it
going to work so we're setting up a new
infrastructure bank you'll be aware that
the government's
very focused on two things leveling up
the country giving as much opportunity
and in particular spreading the benefits
of economic growth and infrastructure
around the country but it's also very
focused on
net zero and reducing the levels of
carbon use in the economy so
the bank that we've set up uh which is
announced uh
and is launching today is an institution
that allows us to think
in a really strategic way about how to
support particular
new projects that may be either
directly green or infrastructure or both
of those things
and to uh bring those
as i say bring those benefits it might
be carbon capture and storage it might
be uh
support for electric vehicles it might
be uh
green hydrogen there's a whole host of
fascinating new technologies and
industries that we need to
get behind and this is a way of crowding
in private investment
giving a steer and giving a support to
some of those industries of tomorrow
okay great to talk to you hopefully you
won't work from home and you will come
into my office
next time it'd be great to see you
thanks for taking the time that's very
kind of
love that thank you so much thank you
thanks a lot still to come on the
program
for you this morning just after 7 30.
we'll talk to the former conservative
party leader
say ian duncan smith about why he voted
against extending lockdown measures
and his concerns about the uk's
relationship with china
five past eight will chat to labour's
chair of the party annalise dodds about
the party's policy review
as well as the rise in covet cases
across the country
after footballer christiane erickson's
collapse during a euro 2020 game at the
weekend
the nhs is sending out an army of
volunteers to teach
cpr nhs england's medical director
professor stephen paris
and paramedic richard lee join us at 8
30.
looking at other stories in the meantime
for you on the programme this morning
shin fein and the dup has reached an
agreement
to prevent the collapse of power sharing
in northern ireland after ending the
stalemate over irish language laws
the nominations for the country's first
and deputy first ministers are expected
later on today
you all know that our our preferred
option had been
for language rights to be legislated
through the assembly and the executive
it became abundantly clear
that that was not happening the dup were
not doing that so we've
essentially stepped around them and we
have broken
what i think has been a significant log
jam this has gone on for 15 years
a survivor of the manchester arena
bombing has said better security at
venues has to be one of the lasting
legacies
of the atrocity the inquiry into the
2017 terror attack will publish its
first report
later on today into the security
operation at the ariana grande concert
adam lawler who was there that night
said he thought authorities had
bottled it trump mentor reports
this is how it started just after 6 p.m
adam and his good friend olivia were
simply going to a gig
it ended in chaos after the bomb at the
ariana grande concerts in manchester
olivia was one of 22 people killed that
night
adam ended up in hospital badly injured
and four years on he's listened to the
evidence about how security on that
night
just didn't challenge the bomber a lot
of people did just
ball it which you know human
fear can be paralyzed by fear um
but you know when that's your profession
of security
or you know policing you know
response it should be to hold your bowl
and go in there
you think why wasn't this picked up on
i'm understanding but i am resentful and
angry
like many people the inquiry is trying
to explain precisely what happened in
the city room
the foyer of the arena a police sergeant
had requested that the city room was
patrolled at
all times that night but it wasn't it
was the arena's own security teams that
first saw a baby
with that big heavy backpack and they
even had people telling them
that he was suspicious at 8 51
salman abadi entered the city room a
security guard watched as a baby carried
his rucksack
across the foyer and then up this set of
stairs
where he sat down for 20 minutes out of
view
it's a cctv black spot he then walked
back out of the arena sat down on the
metrolink platform for 16 minutes
and then headed back into the venue in
the lift
he was seen adjusting wires under his
jacket
after security guards were then tipped
off that he was acting suspiciously
they tried several times to radio it in
but couldn't get through to their
control room
shortly afterwards a baby detonated the
bomb
there were no police officers in the
city room
none of them wanted this to happen they
messed up
they made human errors they made massive
errors
but the end of the day they didn't pull
the trigger he did
and if we're gonna ever really lay blame
on what happened we have to lay it on
him the report into the security that
night
is the first in a series that this
inquiry will release
the findings could have implications for
every
uk venue tom parmenter sky news
manchester another story is making
headlines for you
this morning a new report has found that
nurses
are leaving the profession because they
cannot afford to buy a house as their
pay is too low to keep up with spiraling
living costs
the royal college of nursing has stepped
up calls for the government
to award nurses a larger wage increase
rather than the plan rise
of one percent hong kong police have
arrested the editor-in-chief and four
other executives of pro-democracy
newspaper
apple daily on suspicion of violating a
controversial national security law
imposed by beijing the popular tabloid
had previously criticized china
for tightening control over hong kong
following months of anti-government
protests in 2019
across party committee of mps is warning
that ministers have failed to properly
tackle china's creeping capture
of organizations established to maintain
peace
and freedom the mps are urging the
government to lead efforts
to combat what they characterize as
moves by autocratic states
to undermine organizations such as the
international criminal court
interpol and the world health
organization
the image of farming needs an overhaul
to make it more attractive to young
people as a career
researchers from the university of
exeter say potential labor shortages
could lead
to farms going out of business and
moving overseas putting workers at risk
of exploitation
growing calls for better regulation on
thousands of mobile health apps
a report published in the british
medical journal found that almost 90
percent
were able to access and share people's
private information to outside sources
the most common third parties found
responsible for data collection within
the apps were tech firms
including yup google and facebook
us president joe biden gifted russian
president vladimir putin a pair of
custom
aviator sunglasses during their geneva
summit the shades manufactured
manufactured in massachusetts
were given to mr putin to mark the end
of their talks yesterday
the kremlin has not said whether and how
mr putin
may have reciprocated
china has launched a spacecraft carrying
three astronauts to part of its new
space station
the country's first crude mission in
five years
the rockets carrying the shenzo 12
capsule
blasted off from the gobi desert the
crew is to spend
three months aboard the country's new
space station 236 miles
above the earth nbc correspondent janice
mackie freya has the latest from the
launch
this will be china's longest manned
space mission yet for the next three
months
astronauts will dock with the space
station that china is building
they'll do maintenance work space walks
and carry out tests on
life support and other systems the
shenzhou 12 mission
is a milestone here this space station
is a matter of national pride
that's especially symbolic ahead of the
100th anniversary of the communist party
being marked next month but it's also
strategic
china has been frozen out of the
international space station
largely because of u.s concerns over the
chinese program
secrecy and connections to the military
china is pouring billions
into these space endeavors and every
step of this mission has been covered
on live television there was a farewell
ceremony for the astronauts with
patriotic songs and flags this is the
third
of 11 planned missions to finish
construction of the space station
which should be up and running by 2022.
technonauts apparently are what chinese
astronauts are called we're going to be
talking about that
in more detail very shortly indeed but
before that
back down to earth with a bump the
weather because nas my hay fever
is horrible this morning is it really
bad everywhere
no is the answer it's uh looking quite
wet this morning across many central
southern and eastern parts of england as
well some torrential downpours overnight
but actually elsewhere it's mostly fine
and sunny for today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning lots of sunshine to be had
over the next couple of days across
northern and western parts of the uk and
ireland but
for the majority of england it's going
to remain rather unsettled in fact this
morning
across most of england and wales for
central southern eastern areas that is
it's cloudy there are spells of rain
that are rather heavy as well but
into this afternoon that rain will clear
off into the north sea and it does
become somewhat drier
but quite uh cloudy still across the
eastern parts of wales towards the
midlands
central southern and eastern parts of
england up towards the northeast
elsewhere though some good spells of
sunshine right from the word go a few
scattered showers across the north and
west
they'll tend to ease later on and there
may still be some showers around central
and eastern areas later too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on the program for you um
in just a few moments we're going to be
uh talking to the former conservative
party leader the ian duncan smith
about the extension of the road map out
of lockdown
as well as the uk's relationship with
china
[Music]
about half a mile from the turkish coast
and it's evident that is the
boat seriously overcrowded this is one
of the
most severe viruses in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in istanbul
that's it it got us then
there's a lot of action going on
[Music]
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
her arms look at her arms i can put my
entire
hand round
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
and once it takes a hold it's very very
difficult for these
firefighters to get a grip of it and get
on top of it and put it out
the world's largest folds now down to a
trickle
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so
[Music]
fantastic
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable
to the import of climate change young
people can also become the change agents
that we need to address the climate
impact
in my campaign or in my advocacy work i
work entirely with young people
so that their voices can be heard so
they can also influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in a regard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
done
hi again everybody the government says
it's considering plans to relax
restrictions on international travel
for britons who've had both coronavirus
vaccines
meaning travelers who've had two jabs
might not have to self-isolate
on return from ambulance countries
earlier i spoke to the financial
secretary of the treasury jesse norman
and asked whether the government was
considering vaccine passports
it's certainly looking at all the
options here and we don't want to get
left behind by
countries which may be adopting uh two
jabs approach
uh if it can be done safely and if it
can be done carefully and securely
so people watching at home this morning
over their breakfast shouldn't write off
foreign holidays this summer just yet
okay you know you you see the
fast-moving situation just as much as we
do um
uh uh you know we are we are trying to
move
cautiously and progressively in the
right direction so
i wouldn't write anything off at this
point
on the reports this morning the
government is also
considering whether to give millions of
staff the default
right to work from home unless employers
can prove
coming into the office is essential i
asked the financial secretary to the
treasury jesse norman
how long people will be working from
home in the future
the government's already flagged as you
have indicated through the
manifesto that it is
aware of the shifts in the way in which
people work
and the desire for flexible working and
in this case working from home and
of course as i've said it will be
something that very much varies by
organizations as well as by different
kinds of employees and different ages of
employees so
again i don't think there's a there's a
there's a particular rule that we could
or should lay down at this point
well our political correspondent
tomorrow cohen joining us now hello to
tomorrow working from home at the moment
for covered reasons
um but what were you making of what we
heard there from the minister
morning kay indeed it can make it work
working from home
i think we're seeing the government
looking on all fronts at how we live
with kovid going forward and how it may
change our lives potentially for the
better
first of all on travel um after a series
of government ministers who you've had
on your show
said look go on holiday in the uk
there's some great places
to go looks like the government are and
i want to be cautious and manage
expectations here
looking at uh trying to get rid of the
quarantine requirement for all the amber
list so that would open up
france spain italy the usa all the top
holiday destinations
for british people for us to go to them
later this summer without quarantining
on the way back
now government sources say they're
looking at it there is a lot more work
left to do and of course this doesn't
account for any
requirements that might be imposed by
those countries when you get there
but a glimmer of hope for foreign
holidays
the next review of the traffic light
list is the end of june if they don't
get it done
by then the next one is three weeks
later so potentially in time
for the summer holidays but you have to
keep your options open i think but hope
not just for holidays but people who
desperately want to see relatives abroad
as well on homeworking it's interesting
actually back in the conservative
election manifesto as you were putting
to jesse norman in 2019
the government promised to consult on
making flexible working
the default so perhaps the covered
pandemic has given this the push it
needs
since so many companies have now made it
possible for people
to work from home perhaps not all the
time but a couple of days a week
certainly that's something that's being
looked at very closely
okay tomorrow thank you let's put a
couple of those points along with
others to the former conservative party
leader and cabinet minister sir ian
duncan smith hello tce and thanks for
joining us
on the program uh come to china in a sec
first uh what do you think about people
working
from home more permanently and also
whether they should be able to go
on holiday if you've had two jobs to an
ambulance country
let me just deal with the working from
home at the moment it was in the
government manifesto so they will
be bound anyway to look at this and
kovid as your commentator said
rightly does uh has added a kind of
difference to this process i have to say
i'm a little bit cynical about the idea
uh that people are going to stay at home
massively
rather than go into the office and there
are two reasons for that first of all
the vast majority of people that are
employed in the uk are not employed by
these large companies
that kind of afford this flexibility but
they're employed by a lot of smaller
companies many small companies that
can't afford
uh to have as much of that flexibility
as people have so i suspect this will be
coming to terms
with individual employees about how
things work and the second bit is
actually after having worked at home
many people i talk to my physicians and
beyond
who haven't been forced to work at home
for long periods can't wait to get back
into the office to meet people because
we are social animals at the end of the
day and
whilst uh here we are on this mechanism
uh and we do it on
on zoom and all these other uh items
they're very two dimensional
it's it's um you can do some factual
stuff what you can't do
is really uh play off each other as as
ideas are formed in offices so
so there has to be a balance in due
course and i think lots of people want
to be in offices and also city centers
rely on people in offices london you
know theaters restaurants and all the
rest which bring jobs to many other
people
so this is not you can't be a very
selfish point it is a
flexibility yes but i suspect most
people will want to spend
the long share of their time interacting
with their colleagues
in the office and two jobs and you can
go on holiday abroad
does that discriminate against people
under 30 who have not had a
an opportunity to have two vaccinations
yet
well it depends when he brings something
like this in i'm opposed to
the kind of national passports
internally i can understand why
uh to go abroad to holidays uh
individual countries may wish you to do
this so it's probably
unnecessary maybe that just comes to a
stamp in your passport because you'd
have to have a passport to travel anyway
but um but yes i mean there are issues
around
people who for some reason aren't able
to and can't have
a jab as you say i don't know if we go
all the way down to all the younger
adults so what about teenagers
as well who may not be jabs so there are
there are complications to be thought
through on this one but
if it's what required say to go on a
holiday in italy uh that you have to be
able to demonstrate you've had two jabs
or something like that then
if you want to go on holiday in italy
then you'll have to comply so the
government will have to make that
available to people even if it wasn't
mandatory okay
um you are co-founder and co-chair of
the inter-parliamentary alliance
on china thankfully shortened to ipac um
you said uh that china has a creeping
catcher
of uh international organizations what
do you mean
oh i think china has carefully thought
through uh the failure of the soviet
union
many years ago and understood their
biggest problem was that they
uh their general relations with uh
countries all over the world
uh were were frozen as it were in
absolute ideology and what chinese have
done is managed to separate
from their very strong communist and
aggressive and brutal ideology
but externally to present the face of a
country interested in doing business and
trade and of course
because they were able to produce
cheaper product at the beginning and
more technology in a cheaper way
of course they recognize that the west
the free world would flood to them to
make investments which is
that our achilles heel and we've done
that and as a result of that they're
able now
to with a very large economy possibly
soon to be the largest in the
world to be able to insert themselves
into areas and to
change the nature of how governments
think so for example belton road
uh isn't a a just this kind of generous
offer to the
developing world to ride them with money
comes with an enormous strings attached
to
support for them in the u.n uh a style
and form of government like much more
like theirs they're promoting that the
whole time
and also you have to buy chinese
equipment take chinese engineers et
cetera many of whom never come back
because they're left there um all this
sort of stuff is the heavy ticket
cost of china but china has is
deliberately doing this and the west has
been completely asleep at the wheel on
this one and only just
beginning to wake up to the fact that uh
this is a very very big threat to the
way we live our lives and
to the way that uh democracies are
formed wasn't that what
diplomacy is all about don't we sort of
recognize this
and then come to terms with how we can
work with china so that they don't
take over um organizations in the united
kingdom
and elsewhere in the developed world
well first of all you've got to openly
understand and recognize the
distinct threat that china poses to
members of the free world
secondly you've got to understand that
it is in fact the free world that has
created this incredible leviathan china
economically in a place that the soviet
union could only ever have
looked at and wondered and it's a result
of all of that that is now rebounding
back on us because that naivety of
approach
to china's deep deep rooted uh
ambitions uh is where the real problem
arises and the
you know the brutality of them at home
that when when you cross them
they are brutal so look at india for
example on the border they've killed
indian troops in disputes around the
border they've seized the south china
seas
against the un's prediction they don't
care down about that they're trashing
the the sino-british agreement in hong
kong arresting
uh peaceful democracy campaigners we
just heard about some more this morning
that have been raided and arrested
they're threatening taiwan
on a regular basis you know inside there
i believe they're committing genocide on
the uyghurs an ethnic group the tibetans
now the inner mongolians christians
falun gong this is not
a regime which you can absolutely just
do
quotes unquote business with this is a
regime that has a very clear and
determined view that they will be the
dominant
uh country in the world and more
importantly that their form of
government
that of dictatorial communism is the
form that
will and should be the choice for every
other government
around the world this is a serious
threat to liberal democracies and we've
been asleep on the wheel on this one no
question
saying duncan smith thank you
by the news thousands of irish families
whose homes
are crumbling after calling on the
government for compensation
the bill for fixing the problems caused
by defective building materials could
run to more than 1.5 billion euros
from county donegal our island
correspondent stephen murphy reports
in a remote beautiful part of ireland
dream homes have turned to nightmares
across county donegal thousands of
families have watched as their homes
start to crumble to dust well as you can
see the
the cracks are just getting worse every
day and
all the cornerstones have started coming
away and busting
it's just crumbling away here crumbling
away yeah you can put your hand in
and then the bits are coming off and
it's just
constant the problem is mica
defective building blocks containing
high levels of the mineral were used in
at least
5 000 homes in donegal and mayo during
the celtic tiger boom years
now they're disintegrating more
what does it feel like to live in a
house that is it it really is literally
just crumbling crumbling away from
us expecting that um yeah crumbling away
it must be scary because it's very scary
um
especially when it's so quiet at
nighttime yes
you can hear the crumbling you can hear
the pop cracking
the popping and the banging and some
debris falling off
a short distance away in bancrana is the
home of claire mcdade
originally from london an engineer has
recommended the mica
affected house be demolished demolition
it's it's a hard thing to face stephen
it's a really hard thing to face and to
have to come to terms with the fact that
you know apart from the financial
implications
the the stress it's just it's very hard
to put into words how hard it
how stressful it is
the mcdade and mclaughlin families were
among thousands who travel to a protest
outside the irish parliament the
government now says it will change the
scheme
everyone agrees we have to protect you
know people who've at risk of losing
their homes
we don't want to see that happen um i
think
i can't say today that they will commit
to 100
no because you need to get this right
a working group will now report back to
the government at the end of july
as their homes continue to disintegrate
families insist that anything less than
100
compensation will be a betrayal and lead
to further protests stephen murphy's sky
news
in county donegal
still to come on the breakfast show for
you this morning as the royal college of
nursing steps up
its call for the government to award
nurses a larger wage increase
we'll be speaking to a nurse who's been
forced to live with her parents
she can't afford to buy her
[Music]
and what we found is that one in five
jobs
nearly six million highly skilled people
uh work in what we call anywhere jobs
these are jobs that can be done fully
remotely from home
but they can also be done anywhere in
the world potentially for cheaper
these jobs tend to typically be well
paid in the tech sector
finance professional services and
because they can be done fully remotely
they are vulnerable a bit to outsourcing
and offshoring
as firms look to cut costs and boost
productivity as they bounce back from
the pandemic
so the profile of the individual we're
looking at is typically
younger relatively well paid tends to
have a degree
be a parent with some dependent children
live in london and southeast so these
are relatively high skilled
individuals working in what would
otherwise be good careers
and their jobs can be done fully
remotely but also that makes them
vulnerable and that contrasts to the
past where
it's typically more routine
manufacturing clerical jobs that were
vulnerable to
automation and globalization in the 80s
and 90s
what we're seeing now is a trend where
remote work is really a possibility and
an offshoring is really a possibility
for these white well-paid white-collar
jobs
and i think there are probably three
specific things where
we look for the government to do to make
sure that
we can capture and keep remote workers
here and attract them from abroad i
think the first thing that they can do
is looking at the support systems the
infrastructure so this is not just
you know it includes connectivity and
high-speed broadband but it's also
things like child care so remote workers
can really work from
anywhere in the uk they want to i think
the second thing is rethinking the skill
system so that
every worker has both the softer
interpersonal skills
and the digital skills they need to
thrive in a tech based economy
and i think the third thing that we're
calling on the government to do is to
renew rethink the social contract uh so
that it's adapting and keeping pace with
a more mobile more flexible labor market
in an attack-enabled world
police have been firing
i'm siobhan robbins sky south east asia
correspondent
in bangkok
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
heavy and perhaps thundery rain will
clear england later this morning leaving
it mostly dry this afternoon with sunny
spells
for much of the uk and ireland however
central and eastern areas of england
look to stay rather cloudy with a few
showers and some showers
will be scattered across northern and
western parts of
ireland northern ireland and scotland
it'll be less warm than
yesterday but still humid for
southeastern areas pollen will be
slightly
suppressed today compared to recently
with high levels over
england but moderate for wales northern
ireland and central and southern
scotland
the rest of scotland will have low
levels of pollen currently grass
pollen is in peak season fungal spores
are at a medium risk
and there's lots of weed pollen mainly
nettle
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
royal college of nursing is warning that
staff are leaving the profession because
they can't afford to buy a house
as their pay is too low to keep up with
spiraling living costs
uh let's speak to someone who's caught
up in that challenge and that's nurse
practitioner
carmel oboy hello to you come on thanks
for joining us on the program tell us
about
what the impact of your salary has had
on you trying to find accommodation
morning and it's been really difficult
so trying to have
um enough money to kind of live by and
to save and and to do those things that
everybody aspires to do to buy a house
in a car and i don't know maybe have a
holiday
it's just unrealistic at the moment and
i found it a real a real
challenge so what if what have you had
to do
you were living at home with your mother
and sister etc and your son
and then you tried to move out but then
what happened
so yeah we're all still in together all
all
um ramped up in this little house and we
are trying to move at the moment so
i'm living out of boxes um as we try and
kind of get my house and completed but
i've had to take a second job
in order to kind of find the money for
that deposit
and enough money to kind of be able to
go forward and look at mortgage payments
and all the bills that come with that
it's been it's been really difficult
and and then finding a suitable house in
um
a shared ownership um scheme which is
what i've done
to kind of buy half a share of a house
because i'd never be able to get a
mortgage
for a full share so it's been difficult
when you went into nursing you knew that
the
um the salary wouldn't be millionaire
standard didn't you but you did it
anyway why was that
um yeah i was aware of that and
i i don't necessarily need millions of
pounds in the bank i would like enough
to live on and to be comfortable and i
think that that's fair to say that
everybody aspires to that
i love nursing and i love the challenges
it brings and the the opportunities to
learn and the opportunity to
to do amazing things with with people
and that is the privilege of my job
every day
but i i should be able to to do things
that everybody wants to and i should be
paid fairly
so i'm not necessarily asking for you
know a yacht in the med
or maybe a 200 million pounds yet and
but
i certainly would like to be able to to
buy my own house
excuse me and live somewhere comfortably
with my son yeah the government
announced a one percent pay rise for nhs
staff as you know your reaction to that
it's obscene that really isn't it and
it's political choice whether to fund
nursing or not
and there is money around for lots of
other things
and it's a political choice to kind of
dampen down nurses aspirations to live
comfortably
nobody's asking for anything ridiculous
just want a fair wage
you and your friends and colleagues are
lifesavers
you don't feel that you get paid um
satisfactorily for the job that you do
on behalf of the nation
um what would you say to ministers
watching the program this morning
after years of cuts you know a one
percent pay rise is
is a cut it's another quarter it's a
below
inflation wage it's not something that
that keeps up with the cost of living
and that's all we want to do we just
want to be
paid fairly for what we do and after
this year when people have been
in the most horrendous frightening
circumstances
and i think we need to be recognized for
the skills and expertise this profession
has we are a degree educated
professional
and we continue to learn every single
data to help people that that's what we
do
and we need to be recognized for that
have you found a property now
um i have i have yeah it's been
difficult but yes
and when do you move oh
that's something else again so i'm in
the middle of sorting out mortgage and
all those kind of conveyancy things that
go through that it is
actually really stressful i hope i never
have to do this again
and your boy how's he coping
okay so we're kind of packed we're
living out of boxes but you know
it's a teenage boy in its summer so he
lives in vests and shorts
thank goodness okay it's good to talk to
you thanks for taking the time to join
us this morning thanks a lot
nurse is finding it increasingly
difficult to
find accommodation given the salary that
they are owning uh according to
carmel o'boyle and indeed the royal
college of nursing as well
um she has finally managed to find a
property but she's only been able to buy
a half share
of that property for her and her son we
wish her all the best um when she
moves into a new property meantime let's
tell you about something that's out of
this world china has launched a
spacecraft carrying three astronauts to
part of its new space station
the country's first crewed mission in
five
years these are the pictures up she goes
um china launched the spacecraft
carrying those
three um astronauts or techenauts as
they called them
to its new space station the country's
first crude mission as i said
in five years the crew are to spend
three months
aboard the country's new space station
236 miles
above the earth a short while ago the
rocket carrying the crew
was launched from the oh i don't know
how to pronounce this i'm going to go
with chi quan
satellite launch center i can say though
in the gobi
desert going to be up there for at least
three
months talking about that in more detail
in the next hour meantime quick look at
the weather here's nars heines
hi good morning we are going to see some
good spells of sunshine around for today
for the vast majority
but across parts of england there are
some rather heavy downpours still this
morning
becoming a bit dry there later
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so some good spells of
sunshine over the next couple of days
over northern and western parts of the
uk and ireland
but elsewhere mainly across central
southern and eastern parts of england
it's going to remain
rather unsettled in fact this morning
there are still some heavy
foundry downpours particularly down
towards parts of the south and
east and it's a rather cloudy start to
the day across many parts of england and
eastern parts of wales
elsewhere it's a sunny start it's cool
compared to where
uh down towards parts of the southeast
it's a rather muggy morning
and there are some scattered showers
across the north and west but otherwise
it's dry now going into this afternoon
and we will
eventually see that uh rain move off
into the north sea so it does become
somewhat drier across many parts of
england into this afternoon
uh but it's going to stay quite cloudy
further east of wales towards the
midlands
central southern and eastern parts of
england all the way out towards north
east although eventually it should
brighten up later but where we see the
cloud break and there will be some sunny
spells particularly down towards the
southeast there is a risk of some
showers in fact
some showers generally dotted about
central and eastern parts of england
meanwhile elsewhere some good spells of
sunshine temperatures around average for
the time of year so feeling fairly warm
in any sunny spells a few scattered
showers still
across ireland northern ireland and the
north and west of scotland but they will
be very light comparison to those heavy
downpours across
england tonight it will be dry and clear
to begin with but yet again by dawn
and into tomorrow there will be heavy
thundery downpours spreading northwards
the weather sponsored by qatar airways